[Music]
you wanted to see me no lemon I did
albino ninja look I never should have
interfered with them
whatever this is work husband slash
Uncle co-worker slash little brother
right well she's not ready to move on
it's true I'm wearing a Duane Reade bag
as underwear today oh right and for
whatever reason he needs you too
I'm a mighty great white shark lemon and
you are a remora clinging to me with
your suction cup head I give you a free
ride and in exchange you uh
eat my parasites
at your hair reads betches she's sews
that should they've made me a closet of
clothes
lemon what tragedy happened in your life
and you insist upon punishing yourself
with all this
mediocrity
well because I'm eating a turkey sub
your turkey sub your clothes the fact
that a woman of your resources in
position lives like some boxcar hobo or
maybe it's the fact that while I'm
saying all this you have a piece of
lettuce stuck in your hair
this is the unlisted number
of stone
the most exclusive restaurant in the
city currently
we start
enjoying some of the Finer Things in
life
completely unsolicited and inappropriate
I will only accept it because I love
food
do you know why Jack Welsh is the
greatest leader since the Pharaohs
because he didn't only involve himself
in our work lives but our personal lives
as well
he introduced us to the finest booze the
most restrictive country clubs he gave
us the names of the most discreet
private investigators to spy on our
ex-wives
he held our hands during our triumphs
and our Senate hearings
I Want to Hold Your Hand lemon
[Music]
example you have a million dollar View
that you refuse to acknowledge that
there's a whole world out there
oh my
God there appears to be a gentleman
making passionate angrily love to
himself yeah I know that's why I closed
the blinds in the first place right in
his office
huh
lemon I like to think of myself as a
winner and I like to surround myself
with winners
potential in you let me be
your Jack Welch let me be
your Mentor no thank you
that is unfortunate you've uh
got to admire his persistence and
stamina though am I wrong or is he in
the middle of a staff meeting
maybe you should be his mentor
obviously he doesn't need one
he's got it all figured out
hey do you have a neck pillow I blew
mine up and now it smells like my mouth
I never sleep on planes I don't want to
get incepted are you going somewhere
Carol has a flight to Raleigh dorm so
I'm going with him and we're going to
drive out and spend a few days at an inn
at Nags Head you're going to Nag's Head
isn't that redundant
[Music]
you're going to Nags Head isn't that
redundant
[Music]
you will hand me an envelope predicting
my joke about Nags Head that is solid
Avery and I are also having a little
romantic weekend together before the
baby comes we're going to Toronto for
the G8 economic Summit it's going to be
very erotic look at us being all adulty
I packed underwear that isn't Gray
Isn't it nice dating someone you have so
much in common with like you Avery is a
type a nut job and of course you and
Carol share your trademark stubbornness
we're not stubborn we're principled have
a nice trip lemon break out those
Underpants but be careful dating
yourself is a double-edged sword it
means you also share the same flaws well
that would only be a problem if I had
any flaws not only has your fly open
there's a pencil sticking out of it
good day to you sir
good morning
how is the happy couple today
well it's no surprise we're sitting here
you two have always thrown off that will
they or won't they Vibe and it's been a
real hoot to watch your courtship
okie dokie now when two employees get
married it is my job to make sure that
the employee is not receiving favoritism
from his or her boss favoritism really
he's trying to cancel my show and what
about your little announcement last
night do you know how many fires I had
to put out this morning because of you
and what was that voice it is my
imitation of Drew Barrymore's impression
of that crazy lady let's keep this
meeting short our marriage is a
technicality and it will be remedied
also in order for there to be favoritism
we'd have to actually still be friends
alrighty let's just dive on in
does the employee spend an inordinate
amount of time in the employer's office
compared to other employees well yes I
suppose but only because Miss lemon is
incapable of doing anything on her own
oh please half the time when I go up
there it's to help you choose a tie and
they're all red or blue yeah
are all workday conversations business
related or do personal issues often
dominate discussion including but not
limited to mothers diarrhea having
babies problems in the bedroom neckties
food issues foot disorders having it all
okay yes in the past we have advised
each other for instance Jack taught me
not to wear tan slacks with a tan
turtleneck I thought it looked nice but
he rightly pointed out that it made me
look like a giant condom and lemon is
the only one of my subordinates who's
not afraid to warn me when I'm being too
authoritative or handsome or when you
have eye boogers
have you spent time with each other's
families have you attended special
events together such as class reunions
birthday or holiday celebrations
weddings or extended car trips
are you each other's emergency contacts
if you ever drink together at work
perhaps while summarizing what you've
learned over the day or week Have you
shared intimate details of your fears
hopes and dreams both personal and
professional is this the longest and
perhaps most meaningful relationship in
your life do you often find yourselves
thinking the same thing and then saying
it at the exact same time
I apologize Jack I never should have
tried to Blackmail you I'll sign the
papers but I shouldn't have threatened
your show I'll leave that to the
parental decency groups and I'll back
off on the budget and the butt mitzvahs
okay now we're gonna do word association
foreplay we're done winner slave
uh try to walk like a woman your flies
open Jack
that way after the crash they'll be like
I did see him drinking oh God that idiot
what did he do yeah that's what they'll
say
foreign
don't worry lemon
there is no cause for alarm you are
watching my videos suicide note oh my
God try not to blame yourself how are
you to know that I was in such a dark
place that the smallest thing for
example a close friend's refusal to
reconcile would be the final straw he
killed himself because of me this is
like what happened with my gynecologist
all over again I do have a partying gift
for you lemon this phone I can track his
phone go to YouTube and search Hamlet
the mini pig goes downstairs
Hamlet the mini pig no phone first I'll
watch the pig video in the cab
[Music]
hello lemon what
else that was the idea it was extreme
but necessary I didn't want to be just
another person on your Grudge list see
which reminds me why am I still seeing
new top chefs with that bald spot salad
Ruiner I had 10 hours to force you to
confront the soul-crushing horror of a
life without me I didn't lie when I said
I was going away I'm off to discover
what makes me happy I have to find my
Bliss which for once is not an acronym
for beautiful ladies and short shorts
how long will you be gone as long as it
takes to figure out what's next although
I've only been on this boat a minute
I've already realized two things about
myself one
I could totally be a professional boat
model and two I do know one thing that
has made me happy these last seven years
lemon there is a word a once special
word that's been tragically co-opted by
the romance industrial complex and I
would hate to use it here and have you
think that I'm suggesting any kind of
romantic sentiment let alone an
invitation to scale bone Mountain it's a
word that comes to us by way of the old
high German Luba from the Latin
blueberry meaning to be pleasing so I'm
going to use this word to describe how I
feel about you in the way that our
Anglo-Saxon forefathers would have used
it in reference to say uh
a hot bowl of bear meat or your enemies
skull
split I love you too Jack